I'd like to thank all the other nominees
for being more crap than I am the Oscars
I just got back from an Oscar party I
have no idea how coherent this entire
thing is even gonna be so I'm gonna
start with the big things right off the
bat in case I've run on a steam halfway
through filming this this is what
happens when I don't get enough sleep
which is kind of my life at this point
anyway so I went into the Oscars
expecting to not be happy with the
results because I at this point I've
gotten pretty decent at guessing the
results I I do an Oscar pool I've only
won once but it's because of most of the
other people in the Oscar pool are
really good and I had a pretty decent
showing this year I won 15
I called 15 out of the out of the
categories the person who one called 19
so you know it was pretty close here but
I the big thing is I was expecting three
billboards outside Epping Missouri to
win I'll point out that my Oscar picks
for this pool had that we have to get
them in within 24 hours of the
nominations going live so that we have
to call them long before the four of the
frontrunners become clear as things like
the Globes and the SAG Awards and things
like that go on but that was my that had
been my pick to win the whole thing
and at the end at the time I didn't like
that but it felt like in my gut what was
gonna happen and the closer we got to it
the more I was certain that it was gonna
happen in the more I was certain I was
gonna hate it now I have actually seen
three billboards outside up in Missouri
it's not a bad movie by any stretch but
I didn't particularly like it the
performances were good it was
interesting but didn't seem to actually
know what it was doing like in terms of
having a point there are segments and
bits that are very good but in a lot of
ways the idea of that winning Best
Picture it's not it wouldn't have been a
sin on the same level but it it would
have rang some of the bells of say when
crash won Best Picture again
it's a much better movie than crashes
but to make the comparison what I'm
saying is and three bull boards outside
up in Missouri was it was an issues
movie that kind of grazed against a lot
of things like racism and discrimination
and police ineffectual 'no sand
misplaced rage and and all that but
didn't really make us stance or have a
statement to say about any of them plus
it was all filtered through the much
more digestible protagonist of a
middle-class white woman you know it's
funny how the hell would the police goes
down a heck of a lot he's here her when
it when that's the source so in a year
that well first of all in a year that is
the political climate that we're in
right now and also in a year that had
movies like get out and like the shape
of water which i mean if you gottem call
that a political message film it's a
allegorically so but still a lot of
people from a lot of oppressed and
downtrodden groups did strongly identify
with that movie so if three billboards
had one in that environment i would have
been really upset and i've been waiting
for the oscars to surprise me in a good
way and it hasn't for a while now and
sometimes i don't know enough about what
does actually win to the to feel like oh
that was a pleasant surprise like I did
I didn't see moonlight I still happened
so when last year's thing happened well
but aside from the impact of what one it
was Hall that whole mess with the with
the lalala moonlight thing that was a
whole thing but this year I basically I
got my surprise my pleasant surprise
when shape of water took Best Picture
that made me very happy
I think part of me would have still
preferred get out because and and shape
of water was not on my best movies of
2017 list but that was only because I
didn't get to see it until 2018 that's
the joy of frickin limited releases that
you know are put out and to make oscar
qualifications
you know at the very end of December but
I like shape of water a lot and it I
think it it's very well served to take
this award and I did think that
Guillermo del Toro was going to get Best
Director so I was very happy with that
as well and he he was so heartfelt in
his feed there were some really good
speeches Francis McDormand gave a really
great speech while I would have
preferred Sally Hawkins to win I think
her work was more impressive I was okay
with Francis McDormand winning she she
gave a very good performance in three
billboards and her speech was great her
speech was that big Jimmy Kimmel kind of
summed it up best when he said I hope
she gets an Emmy for that Oscar speech
Jimmy Kimmel actually did pretty well
there was really only one notably cringy
bit which was the whole taking
celebrities to the movie theater across
the street that was kind of dumb and
hackneyed and that was when I went up to
get more snacks basically but I mean
other than that he was fine he did the
job well enough he was the kind of
inoffensive which was basically what he
was there to be as far as the other
major awards I was really I I would well
I would have liked some more recognition
for get out and some of the other major
characters that I feel in some ways like
Best Original Screenplay was kind of a
consolation prize and it's also what I
expected to happen to that movie I'm
still glad it at least got that and
Jordan Peele got to go up there and give
a speech and hope and have an Oscar
Jordan Peele has an Oscar forget out
that's awesome I I would have liked like
I said two for that to pick up some more
Awards than it did but I'm glad he at
least got that I'm glad I got to see him
up on that stage holding that Oscar
giving his thanks because he was also
one of the really heartfelt one so that
went down really well I'm gonna consult
some notes while I try and think Oh
Allison Janney also gave a great speech
I haven't seen I Tania so I can't really
call on that one although I did call
that she
gonna win that's one of the fine things
usually haven't seen more than maybe
three or four of them major nominated
films by the time the Oscars roll out in
any giving year yet I still do pretty
well in the Oscar pool because I know
how Oscar politics tend to work so I
called that she was gonna win even
though I haven't seen I Tanya Sam
Rockwell's winning look I I cannot
explain this I can't justify it I can't
quantify it I just don't like Sam
Rockwell and he's not even a bad actor
but like there's something about him
inherently I dislike and I don't even
mean like when he's playing characters
I'm not supposed to like which is more
often than odd but I mean like I don't
enjoy watching him like I can see people
playing characters that are you know bad
people people who aren't good but I
still enjoy watching them I there's
something about Sam Rockwell I just
don't enjoy watching and there's also
the sort of weird
underlying connotation of you know this
horrible openly racist guy who thought
cop who throws somebody out of window he
deserves a second chance and I don't
want to dig too much more into that but
that wasn't too thrilled with that when
although I again I called it I did
expect that and that one did happen as
far as most of the other ones go Oh
cocoa that was an easy call for animated
feature nothing else was gonna come
close on that so I mean how great how
great would have been I when I say great
I mean awful if boss baby had upset
cocoa that would have been something
phantom thread I thought was gonna pick
up a few things I thought that was gonna
pick up picture I thought it was gonna
pick up Original Score it didn't on
either of those Gary Oldman taking Best
Actor which I didn't call and but wasn't
surprised by when it happened I haven't
seen darkest hour so I don't know how
good his performance was he looked
pretty good in the trail
she seems slightly overly shouty for me
but I could have been the the clips that
they were using so I'm sure he was fine
gary oldman is a very good actor he
generally is adaptive scream play call
me by your name I called that it was the
technical oh the other one that was like
a big yes that I was very happy that I
called was Blade Runner 2099 getting
cinematography Roger Deakins has been
long overdue for an Oscar so that was
very nice to see him finally get that
holy cow and and despite my own issues
and reservations about that film it is a
gorgeous looking movie as as you expect
from Roger Deakins it's true pretty much
everything the mans ever filmed and also
the the vibe of the night was was nice
um I think the fear was something akin
to the Golden Globes again because what
was awkward about the Golden Globes was
you know you had all these women dressed
in black really addressing head-on in
their speeches and their segments all
the issues that have been going on
lately in the wake of me you know the
hashtags me to times up things like that
but about 95% of the men at the Golden
Globes acted like it was business as
usual which was weird and kind of
off-putting that didn't happen like
everybody seemed to understand that this
was a night to to be supportive of
everyone even if you are part of a group
that is not especially you know put upon
at the moment everybody seemed to get on
board with that and there was there was
not only a lot of women there there was
a lot of non-whites getting a lot of
recognition Latin American countries had
a really good showing this year and
there was a lot of recognition of people
who are immigrants who were born outside
this country and and it was it was nice
there was a decent balance
that I'm sure there are some people out
there who would call it overly preachy I
would say well yeah maybe a little but
at the same time what's the alternative
if the Oscars isn't going to be a little
bit preachy it's gonna be self
congratulatory and I would rather see
them pushing for ideas that they think
are worth pushing for as opposed to
patting themselves on the back which
that is just insufferable so yeah it was
a pretty good Oscars as far as these
things go both in terms of the show
itself and in terms of the awards so
yeah I think that's about it I don't
have a bigger point that I'm getting to
because I got I kind of I I really
should have built up the Best Picture I
shouldn't have led with that because
then I could have built up to something
but shape of water I if I had seen shape
of water in 2017 it absolutely would
have been in my top 10 it probably would
have taken number two slot behind get
out so while I part of me will still
always say I get out was the best movie
I saw made in 2017 see shape of water
win Best Picture
I'm good with that so that's the Oscars
that's my weird rambley I'm tired and
really should be in bed right now video
on them did you watch the Oscars if not
I'm sure by now you've read the results
what are your thoughts on them whatever
they are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's all
the stuff to do like and subscribe and
support me on patreon a buy a t-shirt
and follow me on Twitter listen to my
podcast links for everything that I just
listed is down in the description so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]